joining me today is the host of
pseudo-intellectual on blaze TV and the
artist formerly known as roaming
millennial Lauren Chen welcome to the
Rubin report thank you so much for
having me I am so stoked to be here in
person to see things in real life it's
unreal this is very bizarre because
somehow we have never met in person
before and people freak when they see
youtubers on the street and now we're
too YouTube people meeting for the first
time I know I I feel really weird seeing
you in three dimensions it's just
unnatural I feel like I need some sort
of glass between us yeah bring me back
to my comfort zone but it's it's great I
I poked you a shoulder before just to
make sure you're these people always
want to touch me to see if I'm real and
we are real okay there's a ton I want to
talk to you about technically you have
done the Reuben report one time yeah a
little less than three years ago we did
a YouTube week where I was just sort of
reaching out to interesting youtubers
that I thought were doing something kind
of cool and you had a small Channel I
think you probably had like no no yeah
definitely before I had passed a hundred
thousands no it was the early days I
remember I was so nervous about that
call I had to like put my dog in the
other room I was in my living room on my
like dinky little laptop and it was I
mean any time I hope you realized you
helped small youtubers so much when you
you do those types of videos because it
makes a huge difference in our
followings yeah cool well I'm glad to do
it and many people helped me before that
so so I had you on and and you were sort
of just when we went through the list
basically who we were gonna put on your
name came up a couple times people had
recommended you and I watch them your
videos and I thought here is this young
woman who's actually making sense saying
some politically incorrect things and
actually doing something good so how'd
that happen well thank you I appreciate
that
yeah and I think I started off the way a
lot of youtubers nowadays are starting
off kind of just as a hobby something to
do for fun because for all that we rag
on social media I think it has kind of
created this atmosphere where people
feel like their opinion matters and they
want to chip in and they want to
contribute even if they're not getting a
lot of recognition for
money for so it was really just a way
for me to feel like I was participating
and you know the crazy amount of
discourse we were having and so this was
it'll be three years ago in May that I
started my first few videos for a while
actually we're just like those slideshow
presentations my face wasn't in it and
my first ever video I think was about
transgenderism the whole idea of like
transgender versus trans Trender you
know the idea of many genders I think
and for a while I kind of put out a
video or two a month just for fun and
then eventually I started getting more
and more subscribers and after it wasn't
even that long maybe eight or so months
I was able to make YouTube my full-time
job through things like crowdfunding and
it was a it's been pretty crazy right
ever since yeah and you've watching you
mature and I watching your ideas sort of
come together is it totally been a joy
to watch truly yeah so you went for the
first your name was roaming millennial
did you just feel that you needed to
have a moniker and not go by real name I
am just the biggest introvert you can
have her and imagine like I'm the person
in class who never really spoke up and
less a the teacher specifically called
on me or you know attendance was part of
the great grade so like I wanted to
contribute but I think for a lot of
people who are maybe more shy not to
mention the amount that certain opinions
get demonized nowadays you know I felt
like kind of being anonymous at first it
was safer I was less embarrassing people
wouldn't really like attribute stuff to
me I wasn't necessarily worried about
blowback specifically until like I got a
little bit bigger and then I was like oh
maybe it is a good thing that yeah you
know my real name isn't attached to it
but whatever Romi millennial come from I
just totally made it up it was just like
because I've moved a lot and I was doing
some like HR research at the time for my
main job and so I was very entrenched in
the whole like generational separations
you know Millennials versus like baby
boomers Gen Xers whatever so I had I
known I would end up going by that for
like two years and maybe would have put
a little bit more thought into it but
yeah people still call me roaming and
I'm fine with that you know you can call
me ro me or what
I don't mind definitely not the worst
thing I'm being called right now I don't
think unless I'm making this up but I
don't think I am I don't think I even
knew your name was Lauren until way
after I interviewed you I called you
roaming and you just went by roaming and
I was like all right look all around you
know what's funny I feel like people who
spend a lot of time online are kind of
social media circles that doesn't really
bother us because I I don't know you've
had rucka rucka ali on your show and you
know I'm a fan of his love his stuff
he's funny and we all really smart guy I
think people who maybe just know him for
his music don't realize but then I
realized the other day like wait what is
his real name Rekha
well I truly this very moment I cannot
remember what his name I'm fine I don't
know like I know him less as a content
creator because of that you know I
started doing more like in-person events
and kind of you know I was on fox news
and stuff and that's when I was kind of
like for people who aren't in the
YouTube sphere it is kind of weird to
just go by a moniker yeah yeah so were
you always interested in politics did
that was it always saying that yeah I
mean you're your fellow political
science graduate and all your political
yeah so yeah there's three people that
are doing it right Shapiro was also a
political science Matt Christianson as
well all right so there's four of us
that actually degree in your face
everybody yeah I'm using my Poli Sci
degree yeah I've always been interested
in it I'm I'm not exactly sure what it
is but I'm just interested in I guess
the way society functions and I think it
maybe stems from a desire to want to
improve things and I feel like you know
every every job every profession out
there is valid and is making our lives
better I just happen to be interested in
you know kind of systems governments
family stuff like that yeah so tell me a
little bit more about just growing up
before you were youtuber and somewhat
public person you are half asian I've
been treating you as a full white person
here I hope that's okay
you know I have been noticing that
there's been some microaggressions yeah
yeah so I'm all about your Asian
privileged I am half-chinese my father's
from Hong Kong I was born in Canada but
I when I was only a few months old moved
to Hong Kong and that's really where I
grew up
aside from that I've also lived in
Shanghai Singapore in London and then I
came to the states for university so
I've had a pretty like metropolitan mix
background in addition to my like racial
heritage and I think coming on to an
American campus for the first time was
the first time I was really made aware
of my race in a very real way because
growing up your Asian in like Asian
expat circles is actually not that
uncommon I'm not gonna say that there's
a lot of us but you don't have like
quite a few mix kids in the schools that
I was going to like the American like
kind of foreign expat school so I never
really thought about it I had friends of
all different races growing up and we
got along fine I mean I'm not gonna say
that I was colorblind because I knew
like oh yeah this person's Indian this
person was white but it was never a
point of contention or anything like
that but you know going on to an
American college campus it was a whole
different story and I think that's what
was that like when you first noticed
that difference it was a little bit
strange because I remember I was really
excited to go to I'd never lived in
America before I had been going to
American schools all my life and you
know I had so many friends that were
American but I never lived in America
before and I was really excited about it
because in schools I learned American
history and stuff like that but never
lived there so when I started college I
was really excited to get the American
experience because it was almost like
you know the the place that movies took
place in where celebrities were from
where everything I read about in books
happen so I really like built it up in
my head and I was excited to get that
experience but it's funny when I got
there and I saw my dorm room assignment
USC which is where I did my freshman
year they have this thing where they
they kind of segregate dorms a little
bit there's like a gay floor there's a
black floor there's like a Muslim
housing thing and I went to look at my
room assignments and every single other
person that was in my dorm also had an
Asian last name so I was in essentially
the Asian ghetto Wow
so that was kind of like the first time
where I was like wait what cuz I had
never I'd never really experienced being
stereotyped in such an obvious way for
them and maybe maybe was just an
accident but all I know is the
never volunteered like hey yeah put me
with all the other agents I wasn't an
accident there's not that many Asians at
USC that it just like you know literally
every other person in that suite there's
like I think maybe like 15 other people
so I applied for a room transfer because
I was like well I mean no offense like
I'm sure you're lovely people but I I I
didn't come here to just live among
other Asians I want you know just a
general mixed American whatever
experience and so that was like the
first instance and then you know aside
from that I had I was approached a lot
by people to join like you know the
Asians in film club or the Asians in
this club and that's when I started to
notice that race was a lot a much bigger
deal in America than it was for me
growing up in Hong Kong or Canada so I
know you talk about identity politics
yeah a lot now but what were your
politics like before you realize that
this whole thing was happening well I
mean I was conservative going into
college I went to college Republican you
sorry yeah College Republicans meetings
when I was 17 so I didn't have really a
moment where I was liberal then became
conservative but I in terms of the race
issue if it's even an issue I just
wasn't thinking about it right I was
just for like you know economic
responsibility lower the budget etc etc
I think it kind of it made me feel in a
way I don't want to you know sound like
an sjw but marginalized the way that
they were constantly bringing up my my
Asian 'san die think that's what made me
more interested in cultural issues as
opposed to just governmental issues
because I was seeing how how much of
their philosophy was affecting me in my
everyday life and I mean I have people
who you know on my channel they say
you're always talking about culture and
social stuff why don't you talk about
more policy and I mean frankly my
viewership
I think it's 75 percent under the age of
35 and for a lot of these college
students or people who have just
graduated this is stuff that affects
them every day of their life like they
are bombarded in like social media pop
culture with
your races this versus you know your
race to this you can't talk about this
because of your race so for these people
and for
at the time that was the biggest thing
that was affecting us mm-hmm
when you started doing the videos then
were you like holy cow there is a world
of people talking about this because I
mean that's even though I did come from
the left so I wasn't you know always
let's say on this side whatever that
means like when I started talking about
these things I suddenly was like oh I'm
not the only one there aren't that many
yet and now they're kind of growing but
you guys feeling okay to go out there it
was and actually you know I grew up well
I grew up from you know college like
late teens onward watching people like
steven crowder how the world works
Alley Doran he doesn't really make
videos anymore by the time he was one of
my favorites he did sort of the whole
political like debunking commentary
thing and I still appreciated that
because for so long when I was in
college I felt like I was in a bubble
and I was the crazy one I was the only
one with my set of opinions and everyone
else was thought the same way so in
making my videos I did kind of hope that
maybe for someone else out there I could
be that lifeline that's like hey you're
not crazy someone else also believes
this you're not losing your mind you're
not a racist you're not a sexist just
for thinking differently yeah what about
just generally what it's like to be a
young person that's a conservative it's
not the easiest thing and I think in
conservatives especially right now or so
against the idea like victimhood culture
but I don't think it's playing into
victimhood culture to say that it is it
is difficult and you know not only am i
younger but also being someone who's
half asian and you experience this
because you're gay and I watched your
Praeger prettier you show with Candis
Owens like she experiences it because
she's black but when you are not even
conservative but just not far just yeah
and you know one of these protected
groups that doesn't like fit the mold of
who they think should be disagreeing
with them you get even more of an attack
right because then you're called I'm
called things like an uncle Chan you
know Kenneth Owens it's called really
terrible things you know I'm sure what
is it that they want you to believe as a
person with some Asian heritage what is
it that they want you to believe because
it's a little bit different than they
where they can say to gay people I see
we are the ones who got you right so you
better bow to us right or black people
we're giving you this or that what is it
because Asians have been by and large
extreme
yes do the hard work and family and all
those things yeah what is it that they
want you to believe they want us to
believe that white people don't accept
us till CSS other the I've had you know
progressives tell me that the only
reason that conservatives watch me is
because they think I'm white or that I'm
trying to be white or that they're
tokenizing me you know they're propping
me up as a way to say see I'm not racist
which is really what are the most racist
e7o I've ever heard and that's that is
hard and I think we see like with this
like a repression hierarchy you know
they still like to claim Asians as their
own but at the same time progressives
right now are happy to throw Asians
under the bus when it comes to something
like affirmative action which it's it's
been documented actually harms Asians
and it's it's really frustrating
especially I did a video recently on
colorism which if you're yeah the idea
that it's not just race sorry wait okay
racism is like prejudiced against
different races plus systemic power
according to them and then colorism is
like we're talking more about skin tones
so it can even apply to people within
the same race so I did a video about
that and you know frankly I didn't I
didn't even disagree with the idea that
colorism exists and that there are some
people out there who might prefer like a
lighter skinned person to a darker
skinned person because I don't think
either us would say that individual
sexism or racism or whatever type of
prejudice exists right because people
are jerks and yeah but pretty much in my
video I I said that I don't think
there's enough evidence to say that
colorism effects something like prison
sentencing which is a what the MTV video
that I was responding to said and also
that I'm that darker skinned black
people get longer prison sentences than
lighter skinned black people because of
their race right not because they're
sorry yeah so I'm pretty much I was just
saying I don't think there's really
evidence to back this up and I think the
conversation surrounding colorism just
like the conversation surrounding racism
it's not so much a fight for equality
anymore as it is to try and bring down
the oppressors or those more privileged
right it
so the conversation surrounding race I
think has evolved to unfortunately
demonize white people in a lot of ways
and what we're seeing in the
conversation with colorism is that
lighter skinned minorities are kind of
being demonized in the same way and that
that's what my video was about and I got
a lot of people quite upset they were
they weren't happy with that you know I
was told to shut up because my opinion
doesn't matter because I'm not
dark-skinned and so I wouldn't know what
it's like to experience colorism which
is nice a little bit of irony there that
are currently they didn't get able and I
was just attacked for being you know a
uncle chan equivalent just a puppet used
by white people to try and tear down
darker skinned minorities and it's just
I mean I've been watching your stuff I
don't know if you're feeling like this a
little bit lately but I'm getting really
pretty fed up about it fed up of being
told that I'm not special enough in
terms of diversity points to have my
opinion yeah well it's funny because I
think you know this about me my general
disposition is I'm fairly agreeable and
I try to be respectful and all those
things but there are these moments where
I'm like this thing is so dangerous it's
so out of control that there are these
moments where I just want to like
unleash hell on these people I really
like taking them down I'm doing it I
guess it may be a little slower
I completely understand and it's funny
when I started making my videos I was so
under the impression where it's like
yeah other people face controversy and
backlash but I'm I'm so variable and
like I'm gonna explain it in a way where
they can't misunderstand me where it's
like obvious that I'm arguing for more
equality and stuff like that clearly not
the case and I'm still not a provocateur
my goal is never to upset people and I
really do I'm speaking out about these
issues because I want more equality but
I am at the point now where it's
together there's some people who are
just bitter and they're raging
ideologues they don't want to listen
they don't care what you say they're
just gonna demonize you based on who
they think you are and use your identity
to you know call you a whole bunch of
slurs it's quite awful it is quite awful
so I know we could we could sit here all
day long talk about what's going on with
the left and how you know the depression
Olympics and that whole thing do you see
any things on the right that you're
worried
yeah well I think you know politics it's
almost a game of like back and forth
reaction and inaction and then etc etc
and so on the right I'm just worried
that there are people on the right who
are getting so fed up like I am where
they're actually saying for the example
in the issue of identity where they're
saying like yeah let's let's have our
own identity in politics which is
completely the other way of where I
think we should be going and Jordan
Pearson speaks out it about this too
where it's like if you if you don't like
a game that someone's playing you don't
respond by playing it yourself you stop
you stop the game and I think there are
some people on the right that right now
are happy to start to you know buy into
it it's like maybe yeah you we have like
a black Club we have a Hispanic Club why
not a white Club where it's like you
know you have most reasonable people
it's like well let's let's calm down
let's let's stop this so that that's
something I'm worrying about on the
right and just in general there are
people that are so entrenched in the
culture war right now I got people mad
at me I lost subscribers because I said
that the Captain Marvel movie was pretty
good that's all I thought I was pretty
good my brother said he was pretty good
too I haven't seen it yet I was I was
sort of wanting to boycott it just
because of that stupid comment bring our
yeah but I know it's gonna fit right
into I know that's why I want to yeah so
I thought it was pretty good and new
people freaked out and I just hope with
all of this stuff that we don't lose
sight of the reason why we oppose the
authoritarian identitarian 'he's right
we keep things in perspective it's it's
not so we can have our own group that
does the same thing to other people if
so we can move past this and try to
maybe like calm things down where we can
actually talk about issues and policies
rather than calling everyone else and
not see or like I don't know whatever
type of fascists yeah it's so
interesting to me because you can watch
videos that I was doing before the
election where I kept saying if you guys
on the Left that when I was saying it
was alright I was like if we don't stop
calling our own a racist and stop
calling Trump a Nazi and the rest of it
we're going to create this on the right
and it's almost like in a weird way
that's almost what they want to do which
makes people like us our job I guess
that much more important right and I'm
the only hope that I have really is that
the loud voices that you hear online are
not representative of the average person
which I don't think they are right you
have that vocal minority and I think
most people who are just you know living
their everyday lives maybe they have a
Twitter account to follow people they
actually know in real life not just like
this whole political world that we're
wrapped up and they look at both of
these sides and they just think wow you
guys are insane you're crazy yeah well
it never stops right like every morning
there's another headline about some
gender related thing or you know this
reverse reverse racism just like any old
idiotic thing and every day I'm like oh
here's another here's another and then
it's like alright should we stop
fighting it and just let it be or yeah
you have to fight it I I get people who
who say that all the time like why are
you still talking about like X issue how
about you
heart on this enough and I mean on one
hand I say like yeah I like this is the
fifteenth video that I've made about it
but on the other they're still doing
these things so I I'm personally not
even sure what the best way to combat it
anymore is do we ignore it pretend it's
not happening anymore to not Drive more
attention to it but would that just kind
of be being complacent and letting them
do whatever they want it's a hard
balance to strike yeah so you mentioned
the the culture portion of this before a
tagline for your show is it's like the
culture the intersection of culture and
politics I find that I'm not that
interested in politics anymore that the
culture thing has become much more
interesting to me because the politics
thing is after all everyone says it's
downstream right that was like my parts
line it's the politics from culture but
everything has become this right yeah
and it's it's funny because you know I
will have people who'll ask me what do
you think about this bill or this policy
why don't you talk more about something
like foreign aid and you know my
background is in political science I was
a researcher for my professors when I
was in school so I am really interested
in policy it's not that I'm not but I
think that right now what's happened
happening culturally this is we can't
even begin to talk about what for
example presidential candidates think
about that I don't know domestic
spending when everyone's being called a
or sexual predator you know it's just
it's hard to get too political talking
points when you first have to debunk
that you're a white supremacist right
and I really want to get to the point
where we can talk about those issues but
right now we have this huge block in
front of us and I think especially when
we're talking about younger voters which
are becoming a bigger and bigger
influence in elections
so much of what younger voters you know
what they choose to support is based on
things like cultural aspects so I don't
think we can ignore that mm-hmm do you
get a lot of emails or tweets from sort
of young lefties because I think by
default most people are lefties it's
just when they're young yeah yeah it's
media and it's it's Hollywood it's the
whole thing sort of the default position
is your left right I'm sure you're
getting some 16 17 18 year olds that are
watching your videos and going oh yeah
well I feel pretty good it does and at
any time because you probably get the
burn out too sometimes where it's like
oh gosh I've said something and now
people are it is really encouraging to
get someone who says hey I love your
videos I used to be really this way but
you've kind of opened my mind to things
and I don't think identified the same
way that I used to or even and maybe not
even that but just someone who says hey
I'm a liberal I'm on the left but I
still enjoy watching your videos for a
different perspective and that to me is
what's so encouraging and why I keep
making videos yeah so what are some of
the issues that are on your mind right
now so I've seen you do a lot about the
gender stuff and where are you at with
the whole transgender movement at the
moment well it's it's funny because uh
as far as I know I am no way a trans
Fobo I would never treat someone
differently or withhold human rights
from them based on how on how they
identify or anything like that that's be
very clear about this so when they clip
this videos don't have any irrational
fear of trans no no no idea to be
bigoted towards them or prejudicial to
her no no I don't but I think the whole
conversation around gender right now
it's coming to a point where we're not
just saying hey you know these are
people with you know this this medical
condition which been diagnosed like
let's try to support them in whatever
way doctors think are best you know
let's make sure they don't feel
alienated
from that too not only is gender not a
real thing but biological sex is also
not a real thing and also let's it's
okay to give four months to kids mmm-hmm
so the conversation has really really
derailed from where it was I think even
just five years ago which is scary to me
and we do a lot of videos on the show
pseudo-intellectual about how this stuff
is affecting young kids because I think
a lot of people they may watch a video
that I've done about transgender issues
or whatever and think why do you care
why does it matter to you like this stop
butting into other people's lives and
you know I on a person-to-person level
like I don't care what you do your body
or however you prefer to be your life go
for it
but this matters because of systemic
issues right it's gotten a lot bigger
than that we have laws like in Canada
they'll see 16 that may criminalize
speech if you don't use someone's
correct pronoun we actually have cases
now where parents are having to go to
court because they don't want their
children to be given hormones so this
isn't just a this isn't just affecting
individuals and this isn't just me being
a jerk and not wanting to use this
pronoun for you you know I'm talking
about this issue because it's affecting
I think individual freedoms and parental
rights and mainly parental rights
because we see this coming down into the
school systems so for someone that is
paying attention to this that's doing a
lot of videos on these topics for that
very reason are you shocked how much
trans stuff is the only way I can put it
yeah he's just constantly out there like
it seems so disproportionately focused
on it is absolutely disparately what
you're saying yeah no it is completely
disproportionate and you know we did a
video about rapid onset gender dysphoria
because a lot of us kind of just
observing might think wow it seems like
there are a lot more trans identifying
people than before maybe we're crazy no
actually that's correct numbers have
really skyrocketed especially among
younger generations so they've begun to
do studies and they found that gender
dysphoria actually manifests itself
especially among young girls in social
clusters right if there's a teenage or
maybe you know
early 20s girl who's now identifying as
maybe not a girl she believes she's
trans it's actually quite likely that in
her social group there is another person
that's doing so as well so this study I
was actually looking at whether it's
possible that gender dysphoria could be
somewhat of a social contagion there
their phrase not mine
similar to things like bulimia anorexia
and things like that and they actually
did found that yet there's a strong
correlation what that means is that the
people who are saying hey maybe we
shouldn't you know be teaching this at
such young age or maybe we shouldn't be
you know glamorizing as this like new
trend because it might affect people
maybe we are right maybe we're not just
being crazy and bigoted and again what's
the big deal so they identifies a
different person a lot of people might
be asking well you know becoming
whatever you want when it involves
things like hormones and potentially
surgeries it this is a big deal this
isn't something we should be minimizing
yeah have you found it's hard to find
people on the left to talk to these
issues about yes yes it's it's very hard
and the response that I've been met with
is that you know you hate me you're
denying my humanity you want to erase me
etc etc it's frustrating because that's
no matter what someone may call
themselves at the end of the day they're
another person and I I would never wish
them harm or want them to be deprived of
like life liberty or property or
anything like that and I would like to
think I would also you know want to be
kind to them too so it's it is it is
hurtful like having all those doors
closed in your face yeah are you as sort
of hopeful what I for what I would call
sort of the new center right that I
think is sort of conservatives like
yourself like there's just a younger
breed of conservatives that I think are
a little more tolerant on some of the
social stuff then the libertarians say
the classical liberal is the X lefties
that there really is something growing
right now that for all the reasons that
everything feels crazy it's actually
something really nice taking root right
now if you could just sort of step away
from the craziness for a minute yeah I
think so
you know it's very encouraging to see
how YouTube as a platform has kind of
played its own role in furthering
political and cultural conversations
among younger people wait so it's not
making everyone part of the older
I was on that which had no this is from
data and society made everyone watching
nothing but you know there was no
scientific basis for that study all they
did I'm sure you yeah yeah was just draw
pictures to all of our names so you've
been on my show I've been on Grogan's
show Rogen talked to Sam Harris they
drew all this picture and then the the
study basically said we're turning
people are right but there's been
subsequent actual studies where people
have shown that we've actually D
radicalized a lot of people in way so
it's just bananas yeah and actually Tim
Cook I know I was on the chart with you
thank you I appreciate it Tim Poole who
I know you've spoken to about he was
like yeah a lot of my connections
weren't even real I didn't even appear
on shows with these people and you know
I didn't even bother to check my little
connections look at they like they're
not gonna care if I was or if I wasn't I
know that I'm not radicalizing people so
it's like whatever what are you worried
that when things like that come out and
then they put you on that that then we
see the way these things get escalated
where then it's like Oh Lauren talked to
this person who's in a accused white
supremacist and now facebook says you
can't be a white supremacist and be on
Facebook but now you're that much closer
to them yeah and Ruben talk to this one
and it didn't so I know you you've
talking about you spoke about social
media censorship before which I
appreciate because I feel like more
people need to be talking about this and
the reaction that I get from some people
is that like you're paranoid like you're
just you know you're seeing a boogeyman
where there's not if people aren't
watching your videos because they don't
want to watch it like people maybe just
don't care to engage with your tweets
whatever you do get called paranoid when
you talk about these things but then you
have these lists literally linking you
to actual white supremacist and then you
know someone like YouTube comes out and
say they outright say yeah we are gonna
be not recommending extremists or
conspiracy content and you're kind of
like well I'm on that list does that
mean I mixed like I don't think this is
just paranoia yeah to worry about this
and you know part of me like I said
they're gonna say what they're gonna say
the other part of me is like wait this
does matter because this affects who can
see my videos my ability to get my
message out there and never mind
I don't want someone who doesn't know
who I am whatever being told that I'm a
Nazi so they shouldn't watch my videos
and just write me off entirely that's
not a good thing right and you can also
brush a lot of it off your shoulder but
you know we're still people too and it's
like when you go to get a slice of pizza
if there's someone standing there that's
looking at you and they heard that
you're a white supremacist that's that's
no fun
no no for sure and I think people who
fling these words at people online and I
don't know if they really believe it if
they if there are actually people out
there who believe that I am a Nazi and a
white supremacist or if they're just
trying to be you know hurtful and
inflammatory but I don't think they
realize how much damage that does like
not just to you know a platform or a
career but you like personally like you
you kind of have to defend to people who
maybe know you in real life like hey
why're saying that about you because
again for people who aren't in our crazy
online world maybe they don't know that
Nazi is just another word for disagrees
with you right because I mean if you
told me 10 years ago that so-and-so was
a Nazi I probably been like oh my gosh
yeah oh but it now it's the boy who
cried wolf yeah now every time they say
that about somebody or one of those
things I start having to really iknow
even lately I've been thinking about
some of the people over the years that
were really called this or yeah I'm like
man did I really not understand what the
actual truth was and the answer probably
is yes yeah and that's that's a scary
place to be in it when words have lost
their meaning cuz I mean I'm sure you
feel the same way I actually do think
being a Nazi is a bad thing like being a
racist yeah like Bulldogs you're not Pro
Nazism not Pro sexism not I'm Pro good
things anti bad things so like it it's
hard when people kind of just muddy the
waters and it's like words don't mean
anything anymore
and you're called the worst things
imaginable on a daily basis yeah so how
has been working for for Glenn over at
the blaze um because that's that's all
part of this conversation it's like
here's a guy who is I think unfairly
demonized for a long time and who has
also said that you know he was part of
the sort of cable news problem and the
outrage thing
yeah and he's kind of had his Mia culpa
about it and he's trying to build
bridges now and it's
I give that guy a lot of credit no no
one's perfect and we've all done things
in our past that we're not proud of yeah
for sure and I mean the thing with blaze
TV what I love about them is that they
give us so much freedom and just control
over our products so you know anything
you see on our show which all the videos
are up on YouTube now which is another
thing I'm happy for them they're they've
given us the freedom to just give our
content to the general public is that we
from start to finish control what we
want to say I have never been fed a line
okay you have to take this position on
on this topic and you can't say this you
don't talk to this person I've not been
told that where I mean and if you're
familiar with how like bigger networks
operate that's really rare that doesn't
happen all the time and I don't think
people understand that and I still get
people all the time who come to me I'll
be tagged like hey like this person
who's also on Lacey B said this and this
how could you work with someone that
blah blah blah did you see what X person
said is like I don't know what they say
like and they can say whatever they want
I'm gonna say what I say and I think
there are some people who are so into
purity testing that they can't even
imagine a network or you know a platform
where that doesn't happen where not
everybody needs to toe the same line
about the same issue and I think that
like it boggles their minds yeah do you
hold any positions that are sort of
outside of what general conservatives I
think of you a little bit more as a
libertarian generally I actually did go
through my libertarian phase in college
I used to call myself a conservatory
--an but now like with issues like the
the border which I know is kind of even
among libertarians themselves they're
not really together on so like I
generally just call myself a
conservative right now I don't know if
there are issues oh I got one the
environment mm-hmm
I think there are definitely people on
the right who don't believe climate
change exists at all I am NOT one of
those people and then you know going
even further that there are some people
on the right who do believe that climate
change is an issue but they don't think
that government should be involved i I
wouldn't be against I don't know I'm
trying to think of like a green
initiative that I
I would support but just in general some
sort of public/private combination yeah
exactly because I don't want the green
new deal that would be so one of the
worst things that could happen just for
for many reasons we don't think that a
freshman senator who's never done
anything other than win reelection could
write a document that would reorganize
the entire economy and just introduce
ubi is like a footnote yeah and you
don't have to work in Cal farts yeah but
yeah that is I would say that I'm more
environmentally conscious than maybe
other people on the right what else also
the issue I don't know if people on the
right are against prison reform I don't
think they're against it but I think we
don't talk about it enough so I think
maybe I put more importance on that than
other people along on the right do yeah
we'll be making this Trump guy yeah yeah
I think I I think I saw him on a tweet
or something yeah on the tweeter yeah so
I'm one of those people who never
thought that Trump would win and I was
like unimaginable to me but now that he
has I think he's done a lot of good for
conservative values and I am someone who
will never defend what comes out of his
mouth in terms of what he said about
Rosie O'Donnell or who was that who was
horse face again which one was that
someone who was worse like I'm not on
board with that but in terms of I guess
what his administration has implemented
I mean right now in terms of the economy
black people Hispanic people women their
unemployment rates are at record lows I
think that's something that everybody
regardless of how you feel about Donald
Trump as a person should be happy for
for some reason the congressional
Democrats couldn't applaud that at the
state of the yeah weird
yeah that was strange it's like I
thought you were fourth and you know
never mind like black entrepreneurship
is also at an all-time high and
something that frustrates me is that I
get called like anti black a lot and
it's like well policies that I support
have led to this you know led to these
people having jobs being able to start
their own businesses like that to me is
the most Pro black you could possibly be
empowering these people to you know take
control their own lives and be able to
be successful based on their own merit
which they absolutely have have you
figured out any tricks to win over those
young people who are on
fence like just um a story that you can
tell or just a tactic that you have I
think overall just being willing to
really understand what your opponent is
saying does go a long way with some
people because I've had people comment
that I'm glad you don't try to
oversimplify things or you know shy away
from issues that maybe don't make your
side look good
and again like I'll bring about the
environment I'm not saying that I
absolutely do not believe that the
government should be just putting all
the money into solar and win in the
hopes that something happens but am I
gonna deny that I think we should be
talking about the issue of the
environment no I'm not and I think just
being able to have that goes a long way
for some people and then I mean of
course there are these these Ida logs
who you're never going to connect with
and I that's something that I've had to
come to terms with that some people just
don't want to listen and there's nothing
you can say that was going to change
their mind but for a lot of people I
think they understand when someone's
being or at least trying to be rational
and reasonable yeah so even though
you've bounced around the world and
you've done your roaming thing you're
you're based in Canada now is it weird
to you sometimes to think how much of
what you think about and talk about and
focus on is actually all coming from
another country well it's funny I I have
people all the time we say like why you
always talk about American politics I
don't really talk about politics that
much I'm kind of like used to the cold
yeah I goes to the culture and I had
someone I made a comment about the
hashtag my white privilige thing that
was going around and I was told to stay
out of American politics and my response
was like how is this American politics
because these cultural issues they don't
end at borders because the internet
doesn't end up borders right this is
online presence doesn't end at borders
so especially when I'm talking about
issues like gender or race where we have
our extremely liberal government that's
actually putting these kinds of
ideologies into law
I think I'm absolutely talking about
something that applies to my country and
I think it's something that it's funny
like maybe some of these Americans who
are on the Left they're trying to tell
me to butt out
if I were perhaps I mean this is like
it's all conversation but
if I were perhaps an undocumented
immigrant they maybe where it wouldn't
be so like anti-foreign but also I just
I think that some people need to
recognize that culture is it doesn't
stop at borders and so like these issues
affect Canadians these issues affect
Brits and my my breakdown of who watches
my show it's like about 60% Americans
but then I had like a good 10% Canadians
10% of Brits and you know the rest of
the Anglosphere the Australian so this
these really are global issues so
basically you're in California right now
if we could get you to overstay your
visa or something you're just busy
yeah we just get you to cancel your
return flight and then just you just
hide out here we'll make you an illegal
immigrant and then you could argue as an
illegal and then maybe they will listen
to me you'll see how quickly they turn
again exactly yeah I have thought about
that before but now I'm just gonna skate
yeah well that will not go over well
yeah what are some of the other Oh so
you mentioned the my white privilige
hashtag that was going around so for
people that have no idea for the people
that are saying up not to be on Twitter
I so it was this hashtag that was
started on Twitter and it ended up
trending and it was meant for just white
people to check their privilege to
mention instances or maybe trends
they've noticed that are due to their
whiteness a privilege that they know
that a non-white person would not get
yeah and the thing is like I don't deny
the idea of privilege exists like I
coming from a two-parent household I've
lived a lot of places I've gone to good
schools I absolutely acknowledge that
I've had privileges that a lot of people
haven't had you know that's is that
privilege or is that just life
experience you've had a life experience
well I think it's like they're kind of
they're kind of interchangeable like I
don't have systemic privilege but I've
had you know things that afforded to me
in my life that other people haven't had
and life's not fair and I don't think
anyone would dispute that life isn't
fair and that's that but I think you
know the idea when other people
mentioned white privilege they're
talking about the idea that for white
people you know their skin color affords
them certain privileges that non-white
people don't have and I think that's a
very very toxic mentality and if you I
was reading some of those tweets and
like blood pressure just raising through
the roof it's meaningful to read some of
it it really is self flagellation yeah
oh my gosh it's like the you can kind of
like almost imagine these like white
progressives like on their knees trying
to grovel down before their non-white
friends and like apologize for the
whiteness of their skin it's it's it's
depressing and embarrassing to watch I
think and you know they talk about they
like I got pulled over by a cop and then
he didn't give me a ticket
hashtag my white privilige and it's like
well I mean sometimes cops like I
personally i I've never been pulled over
and knock on a ticket I've only got a
ticket once but it's like I've never
been given that kind of you know leeway
you know I've had teachers maybe who
were a little more lenient for me is
that because I'm white or is it because
of my female or was it because I'm a
good student there's we are so keen to
attribute motive to people and like it
just reinforces this idea that yeah
white people are privileged and it's
annoying because now merely denying the
existence of white privilege makes you a
racist and a bigot do you think it's
fair to say that these people are the
new racist like if I was to really pick
like I don't like doing this because you
said something before you don't want to
become well you're fighting against so I
don't want to start walking around and
labeling these people rate racists and
all of the things that they have no
problem labeling the rest of us but if
you were to anywhere does racism come
from in America today it is coming from
the left if where does sexism come from
in America today while cisgendered white
Christian men are this all white people
are this these are these are leftist
ideas that aren't just like ephemeral
things happening on Twitter these are
things that they're that the lefty
politicians are talking about the
presidential candidates that's for the
Democrats are talking about yeah so
that's why it's so dangerous to me yeah
and I agree with that and I would know I
have friends who are on the Left and
progressive who uh who I do think at the
end of the day want equality I think we
have different ideas about how to get
there so you know I wouldn't just base
on someone being a progressive call them
racist but I think if you if you are
someone who thinks that because of the
color of their skin someone is not
entitled to have an opinion about a
certain issue that is
if you if you are someone who thinks
that you know this person because of
their skin color is entitled to either
more or less of a starting point or
advantage or disadvantage then you are a
racist and I think that's historically
generally kind of been the agreed-upon
definition of racist so yeah it's like
there's no reverse racism it's just
racist racism I was talking to somebody
a progressive who's a family friend and
we were getting into it and I said are
you for affirmative action and she said
yes we have to help minorities get more
jobs on it I said are you for
discriminating against white people and
she said no and I said well how do you
how do you how do you know now negotiate
how do you reconcile those two things
and I said well what about your kids
three kids I said well what about your
kids do you think your kids happen to be
white do you think that everything being
equal if they're going up against a
minority they should not get the job and
she said well no because then you have
to take it on a case-by-case basis and I
said well you just reverse argument but
they can't quite get over that sort of
disconnect mm-hmm and that's what I
think we have to keep doing to get them
there to make them realize I think I
think you're absolutely right and I
think for a lot of progressives they do
think that they're doing the right thing
almost maybe even a little bit of a
white Savior complex I would say they
need to come in and rescue them but when
it comes to like affirmative action
specifically it frustrates me that so
many people on the Left are keen to
conflate class with race you know cuz
they'll say like oh you know for black
kids they don't have the same resources
growing up in schools and it's like well
hang on like I went to good schools we
had some black kids that we're
definitely richer than my family or you
know like vice versa and it's like they
were sellout yeah it's like if you want
to have a conversation about class and
school funding then let's have that
which I actually you know I think one of
the privileges that is kind of
undeniable is that some kids are
afforded more luxuries in their schools
or whatever than other kids you know and
an inner-city kid is not gonna have the
same education or whatever so let's try
to address that and say how we can
improve the inner-city schools and
that's where you'd have the conversation
yeah I would agree every exact average
Elementary School in Beverly Hills guess
what it's way more
funded than the average school and the
teachers are there too so so how do you
deal with that okay then that's a good
starting spot but unfortunately that's
not this no because then they want to
make it all about race and it's like
that distinction matters because how we
see the problem affects how we asau how
we solve the problem so it's like you
and I can't just kind of go to them and
it's like hey here are you know
proposals for like budgets or you know
how to deal with teachers unions
whatever for the schools when they see
the problem ask systemic racism like
you're not going to get anywhere with
people like that and it's it's
frustrating because like that whole
narrative and I I get flack I get
accused of like oh you don't really care
about you know the black community or
whatever you're just kind of like you're
you just like to say whatever racist
stuff you want it's like no I am trying
to I make videos trying to talk about
you know the the importance of fathers
and families yeah you know how important
it is to have economic freedoms that
really allow people to succeed it's like
that actually is what I think would be
most useful to vulnerable communities of
whatever color but there's a ton of
evidence that supports that actually
yeah yeah but it's like they don't
because it doesn't feed into the
narrative of systemic racism they don't
even want to hear it and they accuse you
of not wanting to help how much of this
do you think is just for young people
especially it's just the excesses of the
West that we have things have gone so
well for us now for so long if you live
in America you're basically free you are
free you may have problems but you are
free you live in the freest society ever
and that young people now who can play
for at night all day long or watch porn
or whatever the hell else there is to do
or play video games or whatever it's
like they now have to find problems with
everything and what's the easiest thing
to do once you find the problem it's
just to burn the whole system down not
to actually acknowledge that wow this
took a lot of blood sweat and tears of
generations before you
yeah that's such a good point and not
only are people free in the u.s. they
are economically prosperous by any
metric you take someone who's living in
poverty in the United States and you
compare it to a global level they're
still doing pretty dang well you know
someone who grew up in Southeast Asia
you know Hong Kong and Singapore are
very prosperous countries but I visited
to places like Indonesia
Thailand where there like that actually
is structural poverty so you know I'm
able to recognize how privileged we are
just to be in the West and I think a lot
of Millennials now they've been painted
a picture where capitalism has failed
the American Dream is dead
AOC says that all the time like we're
living in of like you know all the
billionaires have all the money the
working-class were screwed we don't have
anything that's not true and that's not
to say that issues like high tuition
don't exist and stuff yeah absolutely
they do we should talk about it but
overall we are living in such tremendous
affluence and prosperity and equality
that the fact that there are people you
know saying no this is so broken we need
to start all over and tear it all down
it like freaks me out can you move to
New York run against a Oaks and find us
some campaign finance what are we done
it would take a lot of campaign finance
to get me to New York I tell you that
not my favorite city but I mean I think
even people are starting to wake up to
the fact like we had the whole Amazon
debacle right and at the end of the day
like yeah people love this sort of like
socialist populist rhetoric but you know
what else they love is just actual jobs
and so what you know when we had Amazon
being chased away we did have like angry
New Yorkers being like okay but wait
25,000 jobs yeah like I everyone loves
Amazon actually yes they're fast even if
you don't work for Amazon you get to be
part of like the growing economy
surrounding and providing support to
that to that business I think people are
at the end of the day what they want
more than anything else is jobs and like
not necessarily the promise that I don't
think is even possible to provide if
like oh just all all this free stuff at
least that's what I'm hoping for but it
is it is really I don't know depressing
frustrating sad whatever negative word
you want to use to see a generation of
Millennials socialists communists
whatever completely misrepresent the
environment that we are living in now
and not recognize how lucky they are
yeah we got to wake these people up but
I guess I guess you're doing a pretty
good job well I you know I've read
people suggest we should have some sort
of
like internship study abroad program
where we just send people you know these
progressive mainly white rich
Millennials to places like Venezuela
places where they can maybe see a little
bit more of the outside world beyond
their bubbles or what they've been fed
to really really see how the US stands
or the West in general compared to other
countries what do you make of a free
college thing I suspect you're not for
free college generally but what about
just college as an institution because
of the brainwashing that's going on are
you even for young people going to
college at this point I have so many
feet cuz you know I'm someone who I
really I worked my butt off when I was
in high school to kind of get to the
best college that I could I took her
really really seriously when I was in
college I worked for my professors you
know all my friends were in academia it
was kind of like assumed because I was
in that world that I would go on and
have my masters and stuff and I have a
lot of respect for academia but at the
same and I would never say that college
is useless but at the same time I think
we're reaching a point now where a so so
much of what colleges do now is not
really instruction but it's
indoctrination and be the return on a
college degree especially if you're
taking something like a Gender Studies
or feminist theories degree or whatever
it may be the the return is not worth it
you're saying you can't get a job with
lesbian Badminton degree I mean its
BuzzFeed hiring I don't that's the only
place that I would know that would look
at it but I think we we need to kind of
re-evaluate how we see college because
you know other countries they have
really they have things like trade
schools and things like that where you
know it's not anti education because I'm
not anti education I'm always pro
education more knowledge is always good
but college is not the only way to get
education and I think colleges if you
look at what they're spending money on
they've really inflated the number of
administrators they have you have entire
diversity boards and things now it's
like where did you come from who's
paying your salary well the students are
and I don't think it's worth it you know
President Trump is actually taking
measures now to try and enforce freedom
of speech on campuses which i think is
really important but I am against the
idea that
everybody needs to go to college the
only way to be successful is to go to
college and I think by by doing that
we've kind of like we've made the
leftists in academia and touchable
because they have like wave after wave
of student who's you know willing to pay
whatever to get in so they can be
indoctrinated but isn't that sort of the
brilliance of it when you hear
bird's-eye Bernie's like okay free
college for everybody so what can we do
we're going to send them for free which
obviously is not free they'll be
indoctrinated into these ideas even
further and then what does he do when
you get out well now you're going to be
guaranteed a federal job yeah that
sounds horrible
can you imagine anything that sounds
worse no and it's like what you can
never get out and you're gonna be some
pencil pusher do ya that's not for you a
cog in the system essentially and what I
think I really haven't seen many people
who are suggesting free tuition talk
about is okay if it's all government
subsidized fine but like how do we lower
cause because it shouldn't just be about
who pays it how much they're paying and
you know costs in the United States have
risen so much faster than inflation when
it comes to college and there are a lot
of different factors like you know like
the student loans the way that you can't
get rid of student loan debt with
bankruptcy there's a whole bunch of
things but I don't see enough people
talking about how to lower those costs
back down to what what they used to be
because I mean you have people who if
you if you go to something somewhere
like USC it's gonna be like what 60 K
air so that's like 240,000 by the time
you're done and it's like it's
ridiculous and it shouldn't it shouldn't
cost that I don't think I made $240,000
in all of my 20s cuz if I took all of
the money I'm sure I didn't all those
years of struggling comedy I decide
that's what you're paying to go to
college no nevermind the interests on
that right yeah so no it's like you know
I on the ride and kind of like centers
we make fun of those people with 240,000
dollars worth of debt for their useless
arts degree by the other day I do think
like I'm not going to deny that there's
a problem with college cost it's just
that I don't think the answer is okay so
just full-on socialism government pays
everything for it I think we need to
have a conversation about how to lower
those costs again and I think right now
students are paying for a lot of
diversity and administrative faculty
they're paying for a lot of research
done by their professors which is I mean
great because American universities are
really at the forefront worldwide of any
type of research but at the same time
it's like at what cost it's costing the
American students and I think Community
College is a great alternative you know
cuz obviously it's a lot more affordable
and heck if you if you still want that
that you know whatever name-brand
University Harvard the big Yale or
whatever you can always transfer after
you get your associates yeah alright a
couple more for you let me ask you some
I'll turn identity politics on you which
would be why aren't there more women in
this space you're one of the few Allie
Stuckey there there's a couple but but I
wish there were more women not not for
identity politics purposes but partly
just a little bit for the optics of it
so that when we're all getting attacked
for all this stuff that's like here's
this here's the low-resolution part of
this
here's more women yeah even though it
has nothing to do with your ideas and
everything else which is really what
matters of course I think the reason why
there aren't more women in this sphere
is kind of why there aren't more women
in politics in general is that this is a
very aggressive sphere it really is and
I think for for me even it's it can be
overwhelming for a lot of people who you
know I write you you put your ideas out
there and then you're gonna just get
attacked like ruthlessly so and I'm not
saying that men don't as well but I
think maybe as a female identifying
person whatever the PC it you know it's
for a lot of women it might be a little
bit harder to just say okay like let me
brush that off move on and forget about
it
especially if you are a woman who's
speaking out against progressive ideas
you're gonna get even more attention
than maybe a white male that's doing so
because I think a lot of people figure
out another white guy who hates feminism
who cares but if you're a woman then
it's like you're going against the green
it's like error in the system and they
really feel the need to double down I
mean regardless of what you think about
the Trump family the way that Melania
and Ivanka Trump are treated I think
most of us would agree is completely
vile sexist of things that they're
they're called and it's unfortunately
kind of par for the course for
conservative women or you know someone
who is gay and speaking out against the
left or black you get that much more
pushback so it I think that alone
unfortunately is enough for a lot of
people to say
I don't know about this I don't know if
it's for me so are you hopeful for the
future you know what I think my my
answer kind of goes back and forth for
that there are some days you know when
for example I see people speaking out
against maybe the Jillette ad and not
being like totally irrational and you
know wanting to burn cards down over a
commercial because that's all it is at
the end of the day but kind of saying
like okay this is stupid
you don't need to do this to sell razor
blades you know it's days like that
where I think okay good most people have
kind of wanted to leave all this
identity politics in the in the trash
great and then there are other days like
I knew during the Cavanaugh hearing
where I'm like okay never mind just this
was a mistake asteroid just we're ready
we're ready so I I go back and forth but
I think you've looking at gen Z they're
one of the generations most ready to
like reject this whole like far left
thing that we've seen in a while so I
don't know about how hopeful I am for
Millennials but I think maybe the the
next generation a little bit more yeah
that's actually exactly where I was
gonna end this suddenly there is this
now burst of younger people you're gonna
you're gonna be old to these people I
hate to tell you it's okay but that are
now coming out and going whoa we've seen
the last five years
abject hysteria and lunacy and now they
are becoming more conservative and maybe
that is the silver lining out of all
this yeah cuz I think and people make
fun of this mean but it's kind of true
where's like conservatism is almost
counterculture right now and a lot of
people on the Left laugh about that but
I mean think about it if you are a young
person who's in school right now like
all of your teachers you know all of the
media that you watch the the school
books you're being giving to that are
given to you they all push this
progressive agenda so what do you do if
you want to rebel against that because
let's face it young people if there's
like tails all this times that young
people like to rebel we like to be
different we like to like I'm doing my
own thing yeah we've all been teenagers
yeah so how does a young person do that
right now well it's not by kind of
committing yourself to PC life and
culture that's not that's not edgy
that's not against the grain it's by
saying no like I'm gonna listen to this
offensive comedian
gonna listen to like you know one of the
people who I I hear my professors or my
parents or whatever telling me not to
watch you know like the Jordan Peterson
is the Dave Reubens the real scandal is
my theory yeah and you know I I don't
want conservatism to just become
something people do to or believe in to
get back at other people but I'm hoping
you know if maybe there's that a little
bit of like tantalizing force to get
them there then once they start watching
the videos they'll see that oh this does
make the most sense so I'm not only
doing this to get back at my teachers or
my parents or whatever but this actually
does seem like an ideology a belief
system that can help people succeed by
themselves and can promote equality yeah
well I just want to say that I think
what you're doing is awesome and the
fact that you've grown so much in the
two-and-a-half years since we did that
little Thank You YouTube Week thing I
mean you're becoming a star in the space
and it's it's great we need people like
you and as Homer sentence it you're a
person like you right I am a person like
me yeah thank you and and you're just
back at you watching you and dr.
Peterson go on go on your tour and
everything it's it's great because it's
almost like this is becoming mainstream
right it's not some like little internet
niche to disagree with these people like
there are real people in all of these
cities who are attracted to these these
ideas and this movement and its really
encouraging all right let's keep going
then for more on Lauren follow her on
Twitter at the Lauren Chen
[Music]